citizens of the reject Nation Coy invited me to
be his special plus one for an event to go watch
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part Uno best
get he's ever one of the most anticipated movies
of the like the last three years or something for
both of us yeah we love this franchise so much
I've been watching the behind the scenes like I I
love this franchise so much so easily it was like
yeah we I'd love to go we started shooting this
at the theater and when I say started I mean like
we just started we got permission but then there
was a misunderstanding so that we had to evacuate
premises now we're in the backyard but guys before
we go on tour review we asked one thing you know
uh jump off a motorcycle and land yourself on
the like button quick little plot synopsis let
me think about this so Ethan on his IMF crew
are back into action on a mission to obtain
this other half of a key they keep reminding you
of that the terrorists and the world superpowers
are also after it because it'll gain them access
to this AI that could literally control the world
so you know they're racing across the globe
there's a new villain here who is a part of
Ethan Hunt's pass from before he was in the IMF
so it's kind of personal and David they've gone
Rogue again you know it goes you know it goes
and there you have it that's the plot of Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part one now definitely
got some positives to go into we talked a little
bit during the credits but there's also some
I would say mixed bag terrain that hopefully
we will know how to communicate without spoiling
very soon so let's just go over the very obvious
positives Cass and actions cooking off Tom Tom
Cruise Tom Cruise is I don't know how he does it
I don't know how he finds new 11s like you know
the concept of turning it up to 11. you think
every Mission Impossible he's found the 11 and
yet he lives it here I've always said he's the
drama Daniel Day-Lewis in the action Jackie Chan
and one very intense body this is that as like
a showcase for two and a half hours the way he
does comedy in this I really enjoyed because it
actually brings in some of his Tropic Thunder
miming sensibilities he's such a good comedic
actor and it's the physicality of him because he
knows how to not only use his body for drama that
is literally not talking but also comedically and
I feel like this is a big Showcase of his comedic
physical uh language the Showcase is that with
action in a way that is maybe the funniest action
of the franchise I think the Ghost Protocol is
the funniest writing but I think comedically this
has a lot of that Jackie Chan prop comedy that
I think Tom Cruise doesn't get enough credit for
while also acting as freaking eyeballs out the
Tom Cruise of it all is is is amazing there's
a reason he's the last movie star I love I'd
love Tom Cruise yeah yeah I love Tom Cruise
very much so too especially on the big screen we
know he has that passion for the action but that
fervor for the intensity and the emotion to help
sell those action scenes that much more he gets a
chance to go back to being a little bit more of
a darker Ethan Hunt this time around I wouldn't
say as dark as he gets in like Mission Impossible
3 but also showcase some of the more comedic side
but there's other cast members here who are also
great who really deserve to be talked about Haley
Atwell I don't know if it's really a spoiler or
not uh not really because it's the first thing you
ever learn about this person she's the thief I'll
just keep it at that she's a professional Thief
which is very different from a professional
spy it's refreshing breath of fresh favorite
new character since Renner she is the absolute
standout in this movie it's so good she works
well with anyone she's bouncing off of she fits
perfectly into this world her chemistry with Tom
Cruise she's Tom Cruise movies she's great like
this is a star to match Tom Cruise's charismatic
star capabilities by far and before we go into
some action scenes I think another one who dude
the surprise of the movie for me can I please hop
Clemente five for years it's actually pronounced
clementia oh excuse me I had to learn that to make
sure I interviewed her when I talked to her and I
was like missed on the teeth Palm is a force in
this I'm always struck by how passionate she is
how intense she is and how like joyous and bubbly
she is but in an intense way that isn't cloying
it's a really hard line to walk to be like that
much of an energy believe me I know I'm a lot
the way they use the energy of palm in this is
so different than mantis it's so different than
you've ever seen and she's terrified she's got the
thing that I think a lot of action movies try to
do or they do the Silent Assassin she's just quiet
she's not silent they do it I think the best I've
ever seen in modern Cinema so impressed with her
she is like a sledgehammer what I think they did
better here with her is what I wanted out of what
they did like I enjoy Henry cavill's presence in
Fallout but they set him up in Fallout as like
he's the guy who's sitting to get the job done
he doesn't play by anybody he's really he gets his
ass kicked a lot in that movie it doesn't really
seem like the guy you send in to get the job a lot
of the time she is she is that thing that I wanted
Henry Cavill to be that they kept saying Henry
Cavill would be she's not really given like a
crap ton of lines but you could tell she's having
fun with this role and especially as so many of
us know her as mantis this is the antithesis but
also it's like so maniacal and gleeful I loved
her presence here I thought she was great the
rest of the cast as we know you know generally
pretty great you know Rebecca Ferguson Ferguson
she's not in it that much but when she's there
it's effective literally shows up on screen and
you're just like oh I remember what happiness is
heartfelt sincere Luther vandro like the rest of
the cast's really good now the action scenes this
is like the main thing people show up for right
there are some stupendous action scenes in here
I would I would absolutely say the one that you
see teasing the trailer a lot of the time where
it's Tom Cruise and Haley Atwell who are like
handcuffed while inside of a car I would say my
favorite action scene of the movie Coy was talking
a lot about the comedy that can be infused in some
of the action here I really thought they had a
great bounce that like that was a scene that was
truly exciting intense also was making the theater
laugh a lot yeah because intentionally though like
they had things in there and the other thing too
they go through a lot of the same locations that
they go through in the car chase scene and the
bomb and fast hex like literally some of the
exact same spots and it was cool to watch it here
because you're like but this is real like these
are locked off shots you can tell there's none of
the CGI stuff happening here because that's the
mission impossible the franchise Thrive so much
on so it's cool to get this comparison and it felt
that much more vital and real because we just saw
one that had used a lot of crazy fantasy action it
literally like a one-to-one ring old style movie
making new style movie yeah and it's beautiful to
see how they do yeah it's Carnage this feels like
when you're a kid and you go see a blockbuster and
I feel like that's now been made into a negative
people are saying that derogatory they're like oh
it's a blockbuster when we used to say that it
meant a good thing and I'm using it that way it
feels like going to the movies and having yourself
some popcorn but not in a way that dumbs down the
experience it's just so joyous there's some stuff
if I have a bit of a mixed opinion on I don't know
someone else who sought a different screening and
they said their crowd was losing their [__] on
the part where the one they've been promoting
a lot where he jumps off the cliff with the
motorcycle free Falls I had a different experience
here where I was I was let down by the overall
scene because the stunt in and of itself is so
goddamn dangerous and so impressive yet in terms
of it being a scene I feel like there's no reason
not a lot of early reactions have actually been
highlighting this moment because more than a lot
of the other stunts in this franchise it really
felt like Tom Cruise he wanted to do a stunt
and he got to do the stunt and the stun in and
of itself is cool and but normally the build up to
the stunt is tense then the stun scene itself is
super intense but here the build up is tense but
the actual stunt while still cool surprisingly
doesn't feel as impactful of a scene I think my
issue was in the edit because I was invested in
the stunt and I was invested in the other plot
that was happening but I think the choice to leave
the stunt when they did to go to the other plot
and then come back under your mind both of them
because yes they're tonally so different you were
like I want to know more about I guess I want to
stay here do I stay here yeah the momentous build
up to the sun kind of felt like it kept getting
interrupted instead of ramping up excitement to
it it makes you not enjoy the juxtaposition as
opposed to being like I'm fraught with Peril
you're like wait now I'm undermined the other
part of it is because this is an insane thing that
they did if you watch the behind the scenes of it
it is a gnarly thing and it's the reason why
they've been promoting this stuff it's easily
the craziest stunt of this is It's the stunt of
the movie The issue is is that that stunt in it
of itself makes for just a short-lived moment
and not a full scene if you think about like
even him going underwater even though there's a
CGI enhancements that seems like a few minutes
hanging on the plane that's a full scene I'm in
the burst it's a full scene so even if you see
the behind the scenes you still get the drama of
that scene and here it's like he's off the cliff
exactly as long as it is in the trailer and now
and that does change the intensity because you're
like wait I've seen this but I know some people
who were who started I want to see it with a
crowd that has that reaction we saw it with
a full crowd and no one reacted to it but I
wanna I wonder if we would react differently
with a crowd definitely definitely cheering
and then the other big one that's been teased a
lot and this is the one I see people constantly
talking about social media is the train sequence
now here's where I feel like I'll have the most
unpopular opinion it would be such a spoiler for
me to tell you what this train sequence entails
the best I can say without spoil is it kind of
reminds me of of a part of Uncharted 2 I would
say this train seems a loving concept I could tell
a lot of the crowd was on the edge of their seat
the thing that was kind of pulling me on here's
where I'm gonna sound like a total [__] I know
it's just a fact of the matter is that preceding
this moment there was already some stuff on top
of the train that was super CGI the thing is
this the mission impossible franchise has been
so well revered for they don't do CGI and if
they do it's only to help hide some stuff but
not such a thing that will overshadow a moment
I found moments being very much overshadowed by
that and in this particular train seeing us a
lot of people are really much crowding I love
the concept of it obviously the whole thing with
like the performers are not CGI you can tell the
performers are really doing stuff but a lot of
their surrounding Landscapes I still felt like
they were encapsulated and ultimately what was a
green screen and maybe I'm wrong but it certainly
looked that way and I think that's the difference
and that's what would make me not feel the danger
to the sequence this is a weird thing to be like
I wish they were really doing this and that makes
your life more because I'm so used to Mission
Impossible doing that because I'm so used to this
franchise doing that it distracted me that much
more so I wasn't able to get as immersed into the
suspense like obviously these guys will be fine by
that we've seen every Tom Cruise stunt and you've
seen promoting the movie so we know they're gonna
be fine in the end these actors but the idea is
to be so immersed into the moment that you forget
about that and I hear I never forgot about it and
when you said that in the credits we were talking
about that scene I immediately was like oh you're
right and I acknowledged it and in hindsight
I can take myself out and I was like oh that
would have removed me but since to me I was so
focused narratively on some of those elements it
didn't pull me out until he said it and then I was
like so I think you'll have one or two experiences
I didn't say it while you were watching he was
like hey do you know who said oh full moon how
to ruin this moment loudly over the thing no but
like when he mentioned in the credits I was like
oh you're right but I in in hindsight I can
acknowledge that so I think you viewer will
either have the experience where you're so in
you can acknowledge it after or you uh you'll
have like Greg's experience where you're like man
we're in this and I do want to say while we're
talking about stunts in this franchise this is
an action franchise that I would put above 90 of
action franchises It's tricky because this mixed
bag stuff we're on now is because it's not over
90 of the mission impossible stunts in action it's
grading on a bell curve Mission Impossible is so
far above everything else that we're saying this
in compared to itself but it's still better than
90 of action movies ever made so I would say like
this is around the middle of my Mi experience but
that's still in my top five percent of action
movies okay this is there's seven movies right
yeah I would easily place because here's the
thing guys I love absolutely love three through
six so four films I love right three four five
six seven three I I love three through six this
one I liked and I feel like I'll like it even
more in a second viewing here's the thing and
maybe this is why I wasn't as wrapped up in the
narrative so to speak like you were saying with
that train sequence which is this movie's two
hours and 43 minutes there's a lot on on paper
that I appreciate about what they're going for
and when the two hour 43 minute run time most
of it is not action it shouldn't be action I'm
not saying that's the problem the parts where I
would say is it's not all negative and you know
if I have a super negative about it I would not
watch my words I would tell you guys if I was just
like oh my God I hate this or I was bored it was
such a fluctuating mixed bag for me with most of
the movie in terms of everything that surrounded
the action scenes that would lead into the action
scenes that sometimes it would actually take away
some of the excitement and pulse pounding nature
of the action because I wasn't enjoying the stuff
that was in action as much I mean there are
elements where it seems like they're aiming
to capture that specific dark Espionage tone
from the first mission impossible movie which
I do appreciate the best way I could say it is
this is in the most simplistic terms is like it
has all the ingredients of all the other things I
loved and all the other Mission Apostle movies for
the things that were not action I mean Christopher
McCrory wrote and directed this movie and he wrote
and directed the last two that I absolutely love
the recipe that was ultimately cooked up okay I
get that they're going for something that's a
little bit more topical to today sometimes the
commentary feels like way too heavy-handed I feel
like someone is talking ideas at me and not really
living so much in the moment not all the time but
a good amount of time a lot of the time it feels
like they're going for something that is darker
but it doesn't resonate as menacing or intense
it can just resonate as dramatic dour so it loses
a little bit of life not all the time but a good
amount of the time it can feel that way maybe
it only stood out to me this time on my first
go around and maybe I won't have it as much of my
Takeaway on a second go around but on my first go
around it would definitely impact the way I would
ultimately feel about sometimes when we get to an
action figure sometimes I have to feel like I'm
relieved we're at an action scene right now as
opposed to attention as opposed to like we built
up to here yeah which is like the other movies
did it so well I know some people will come at me
and be like we're just taking out some merits this
is number seven and this is clearly a movie that
is not Standalone also we're fighting over which
one is like the yeah or fourth best in a film
of seven like that's how good these movies are
we're like what's the fourth fifth best of a seven
like they're all that good but if you want honest
opinion like I I have some similar qualms with uh
the movie's got an AI element that is the plot I
felt that at times I was impressed that 20 years
ago when the first one came out the plot itself
would be a Sci-Fi this would be like oh my God
Blade Runner now it's present now it's a topical
like you said and sometimes I was like man they
trust the audience they're letting us just have
this they're spoon feeding us and then other times
it's like here's a shovel of data and I was like
you just trusted us so much so much Exposition so
many cases the way they go over the key I made it
think about the key the key thing in the plot
when I was talking about the plot because they
kind of treat the audience like they're an idiot
in the first and then sometimes they don't and
I'm like where's this writing so I would say that
while we're judging the action also in the script
element there are times that it's that clever
Mission Impossible highbrow intellectual action
film and other times where it's like oh we're
releasing a movie against other things we got
to make sure everyone gets it and I've never felt
in that mission possible I've never felt they were
like let's just just take it down and I'm like
don't do that to me trust me this is seven how
I'm imagining someone hearing what we're saying is
going like but I feel like the other movies kind
of did that I'm like yeah they they do they just
do it better it's like you're baking this is also
two hours and 40 minutes so this also gestates a
lot longer to keep with that the souffle sometimes
too hot sometimes not hot enough exactly false
and sometimes it burns it really needed a kind of
a punch-up it was the first time and I know that
they they must do these for the other ones this
was the first time I really felt like they came
up with action scenes first and then they thought
of plots to to work their way to them a lot of
the time and I and this is the first time I was
distracted by that there's clearly other moments
like that in the other movies but here I felt that
a little bit more and then they have this other
villain here Isaiah Morales I think is the same
yeah they do have something in here with him that
is an attempt to make it a more personal villain
for Ethan Lincoln to his past but it honestly
feels like some stuff they made up just for this
movie not like it's always been a part of the
character so it doesn't really land that strong
he's a Charming actor but after the villain
that we got in the last couple I'm like
I don't know it's like it's kind of the problem
I have with the way a lot of these characters
are written this time around everyone is just
given like like you said data everyone's just
given explained [__] everyone's given exposition
to the point where I never felt that yeah we're
like of course these movies have Exposition this
is the thing it's like when you say stuff you're
like the other movies do it yeah we see you coming
the way this movie does it is I feel like a lot of
time I was listening to ideas in an outline less
than I was listening to characters yeah yeah and
also there's some style choices that make it more
severe I think you and I talked about the like 180
rule a couple times that's super dirty film stuff
but there are times where it shot distractingly
avant-garde and like it it causes a certain like
paranoia and Noir but sometimes it doesn't fit
the tone or it does like this break of the 180
rule where you're like I feel like I'm watching
the BBC behind the scenes of the scene and I'm
like wait we were just with this character why
are we over here in this room I think meant to be
disorienting but it's disorienting in a way that's
like it feels messy and not a a style Choice
yeah it just felt messy to me I feel like we
got so caught up in trying to communicate that it
was just a mixed bag and that we're not negative
like watch this on the big screen because it's so
certainly worth it and I am definitely excited I
can't wait to get this movie yeah I can't see
it that's the thing it's like Indiana Jones I
canceled all things I had to watch it again I was
like no I don't care to watch it again this one I
have tickets to go watch it again and I'm like
I'm looking forward I'm still looking forward
to it I think we were positive for 10 minutes and
then negative for two but we're so in love with
the movie that it's like man those two felt bad
like the act of saying bad things about something
you've enjoyed is hard so like I enjoyed a lot so
it's still like a mission impossible movie it's
still one of the best action movies ever made it's
just uh we're trying to be honest I am considering
the fact that like no the main things you show up
for really more than deliver so I would still give
it an 8 out of ten just due to that fact you know
what I mean but overall for me like my personal
feeling on a first go around I would say it's
7.5 I'm between 7.5 and 8.5 and my overall just
feelings I would say say for a mission impossible
it's a 7.5 for an action movie it's a nine so it
lands that anymore better yeah like that's so
that's where it is it's just there's two scales
there's the mission impossible scale there's the
action movie scale and it's high in the action
movie scale and good on a mission impossible scale
it would be easier to talk about this movie if
people were just plain and simple like just purely
negative then I could just like be super blunt
but I'm like but I don't want people to think I'm
going to see it it's one of those where I get so
caught up in my head and now I'm just talking way
too much yep for 20 minutes all right guys well
Mission Impossible movie leave your thoughts down
below I gotta get to cut her this oh my God this
what you have out here on YouTube it is nowhere
near as long as coin I have this is a benefit when
you're at a theater is it forces you to be honest
we should have let him check us out sooner [Music]